ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันอังคารค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
12 เงินอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565  a  Call ศ.อะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 11 เดือนเดือน
หน้าตาคม AE ผช
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีพ 2  0  2  2 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 13 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมมีผช
ปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะ
ครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 12:00 น
เที่ยงกี่นาทีคะ
12:31 นาทีค่ะก็เรียง 31 นาทีครูฟ้า
กินข้าวหรือยัง
กูป๊ากินข้าวแล้วค่ะไม่ใช่ค่ะหนึ่งขนมค่ะ
ครูป๊า
ฟ้า
ผู้หญิง
เบิ้ลเขาหรอไปใช้ผู้หญิงเคยเป็นคนฟ้า
วันว่าเรามันขึ้น Double น่ะกูฟ้าอะไรคะ
โต๊ะใส่หากินข้าวหรอชัยอุปฟ้าเนี่ยอ่ะแต่
ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเราว่าทำไมตั้งนาน
ยังยังยังไม่ได้กิน 5 นาทีเอาคืนมองนะคะ
กำลังจะบอกว่ายังไม่ได้กินข้าวเลยหิวมาก
ไหมเวลาคนไม่ได้กินข้าวเนี่ยจะหิวนะหิว
ใช่แต่ผู้หญิงอะไรกินข้าวแล้วกินข้าวแล้ว
เนี่ยไม่หิว
ค่ะถูกรหัสถ้ากูหญิงกินข้าวแล้วหิวผู้
หญิงกินข้าวทำไมอ่ะสวยใช่เราจะบอกว่าคน
กินข้าวแล้วเนี่ยไม่หิวแต่อาหารที่กิน
เข้าไปเนี่ยมันไม่ดีไงครูฟ้า
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงกินอะไรผู้หญิงกินไข่
มี
อะไร Potato โอ้ย
ฟุตบอลเหรอผู้หญิง
ค่าพิซซ่า
2 ไม่รู้จักพิซซ่าหรอคะพิซซ่าแล้วก็มี
สอศ.
สอน
มันเกิดเทสีแดงๆ
มีชีสสีขาวเนี่ยหมอมีสีขาวเลยนะคะ
พิซซ่าค่ะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงอยากกินพิซซ่าเข้า
ไปอ่านี่ชีสน่ะจะคิดว่าชีสไม่โอเคหรือ
เปล่าอ่ะเพราะว่าชีสเนี่ยทำมาจากนมใช่
มั้ยนมๆให้เราเป็นคนธรรมดาใช่นมวัวหมอ
อะไรคะนะ
หนูมวยคุณ
ผู้หญิงดูสิวัวเหรอ
เวลาแล้วก็จะมีถัง
มอก๊ายนมวัวแล้วพับครึ่งคิดว่าครูหญิง
เนี่ยเวลาที่กินหรือว่าดื่มอะไรที่เป็นนม
วัวเป็นนมอ่ะของไม่โอเคมันจนปวดท้องแล้ว
ก็แบบอยากจะไปที่นี่ค่ะ
ไปไหนคู่หญิง
นี่ค่ะ
ที่ไหนคะครูฟ้า
ที่มัน
ห้องน้ำค่ะตื่นเต้นไหวห้องน้ำสร้างน้ำ
เวลาปวดท้องก็ต้องไปห้องน้ำเนาะโอ๊ยปวด
ท้องแล้วไปห้องตอนไม่ได้นะคะปวดท้องแล้ว
ต้องไปห้องน้ำ
งอนี้ก็คือผู้หญิงเนี่ยปวดท้องนะคะ
ทำไมหน้ากูหญิงซาลาเปาเลยอ่ะผู้หญิงปวด
ท้องไงอ๋อเปิดท้องออกปวดท้องแล้วต้องไป
ห้องน้ำ
แล้ววิ่งๆๆ
ตีผู้หญิง
กูมาทำไม่ได้ค่ะเพราะว่ากูฟ้าเป็นไม่ใช่
คนแชร์เอาเหรอนี่ไงกูหญิงใช่ไหมผู้หญิงก็
ไม่สามารถที่จะเลือกของฟ้ามาได้ใช่ไหมไม่
ได้ง่ายๆค่ะน้องว่าเองค่ะผู้หญิงเสื้อไหม
ผู้หญิงแย้ปวดท้องฟ้าว่าหน้ายังไงล่ะคะ
นั่นแหละ
ผู้หญิงนี้ผมนะนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงก็ต้องวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่ง
วิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งวิ่งมา
มีห้องน้ำนี่มาเข้าห้องน้ำ
จะว่าผู้หญิงดีคำถามถามครูฟ้าค่ะ
ถามว่าอะไรก็เติมหัวเหรอคะข้าวเสร็จ
r-cooh หญิงมีหัว Only นักเรียน
ผู้หญิงวิตัวด้วยแต่ผู้หญิงยังว่าไม่
เสร็จนี่ไงเดี๋ยวเอาสีอื่นแล้วกันน้องนัก
เรียนจะได้ดูแล้วแบบเออเออดูแตกต่าง
ได้วันอังคารก็สีชมพูแล้วกันนะคะ
มีสมัยเราเข้าห้องน้ำเวลาที่ครูฟ้าเข้า
ห้องน้ำอ่ะคือผู้หญิงถ้าเข้าห้องน้ำเวลา
ปวดท้องใช่ไหมปวดท้องเข้าห้องน้ำเนี่ยมัน
ต้องใช้เวลานานมันอาจจะประมาณเนี่ย 3
นาทีเนี่ยจะต้องมีพิกเกอร์ warning แล้ว
นักเรียนกินข้าวนะคะโดยตีแว่นตัวเองนะคะ
อ่าดีแล้วแหละหนูรักผู้หญิงเข้าห้องน้ำ
อ่ะ 3 นาทีใช่ไหมผู้หญิงเนี่ยต้องมี
โทรศัพท์มาด้วยผู้หญิงต้องเล่นโทรศัพท์
ด้วยเวลาเข้าห้องน้ำยาที่ถูกฟ้าปวดท้อง
แล้วก็อยากจะไปเข้าห้องน้ำเนี่ยนั่งมันๆ
กูฟ้าเอาโทรศัพท์มาเล่นด้วยไหม
แน่นอนหากผู้หญิงกูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบเล่น
โทรศัพท์มากๆเลยนะคะ
ชอบมากเวลาคุณฟ้าไปห้องอะไรคะเขาผู้หญิง
หรือว่าครูบาจะโชว์เคสโทรศัพท์ใหม่โชว์
โทรศัพท์กับผู้หญิงเวลาครูฟ้าเนี่ยไปห้อง
น้ำเนี่ยมันก็จะเอาโทรศัพท์แล้วก็ไปนั่ง
เล่นนั่งเล่นโทรศัพท์นั่งเล่นโทรศัพท์ชัย
อ่ะทุกนักเรียนเป็นไหม
ใช่นักเรียนอาจจะไม่เอาโทรศัพท์ไปก็ได้
นักเรียนอาจจะอ่านหนังสือ
ในห้องน้ำมีแต่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้านะคะเป็น
คนที่ต้องมีโทรศัพท์นะคะ
ไม่มีใครโทรศัพท์ใช้หวิงโทรศัพท์มากกว่า
ครูฟ้าเอ้าผู้หญิงแบบนี้ล่ะหาวันนี้ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยร้านโทรศัพท์นะคะแต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นิดหน่อยนะคะผู้หญิงรักเวลาผู้หญิงไปห้อง
น้ำเนี่ยก็เล่นโทรศัพท์ไปด้วย
แล้ว
ครูบาก็เหมือนกันใช่ไหมใช่กูเขาก็เล่น
โทรศัพท์เล่นโทรศัพท์ไปด้วยนะคะเล่น
โทรศัพท์เล่นโทรศัพท์
ผู้หญิงก็เลยมีคำถามค่ะกูฟ้า
ถามว่าว่าอะไรคะคุยถามว่าถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
นะคะกูฟ้าในเอากูฝาเนี่ยเข้าห้องน้ำเสร็จ
แล้วนะเนี่ยหูฟ้าก็
ลุกขึ้นใช่ไหมเข้าห้องน้ำเสร็จแล้วนะอ่า
หัวนักเรียน
เร็วๆว่าเป็นคนนานแล้วชายฮะแล้ว
ครูฟ้านะเล่นโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมเข้าห้องน้ำทำ
อะไรเสร็จแล้วก็ลุกขึ้น
โทรศัพท์ของครูฟ้าเนี่ยอุ้ย
ลงไฟในชักโครก
ครูฟ้าจะทำยังไง
ชนถามแรกนะคำถามข้อที่ 1
ค่า
โทรศัพท์ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตกลงไปใช่มั้ยตกลงไป
ในชักโครกเจ้าถามที่ 1 นะครูฟ้าเก็บ
จะขึ้นมาไหม
เก็บนี่ถ้าผู้หญิง
เก็บแน่นอน
100 เปิดเบอร์
ใหม่จะต้องเก็บโทรศัพท์ขึ้นมาไม่ได้นะผู้
หญิงนะคะไอโฟนใช่ไหมลูกค้าเนี่ย iPhone
ตกแล้วกูฟ้าต้องเก็บแขน
ขวาเก็บขึ้นมา iPhone  84 มีแล้วหรอคะ
iPhone  84 ค่ะไม่ของแวน Story
กู้ไฟล์นึงขึ้นมา
ขอโทษนะคะนักเรียนมีติ๊กเกอร์บอร์ดด้วย
น่ะถ้า
โทรศัพท์ที่ตกลงไปในห้องน้ำเนี่ยที่ตกลง
ไป
เองอ่ะ
ไม่รู้จะสองทุ่มไปในช็อคร็อกอะรู้ฟ้ายัง
ไม่ได้กดน้ำมั้ง
ฟ้าทำยังไง
รูฟ้า
ก็หยิบขึ้นมาค่ะ
ผู้หญิงแล้วไม่หยิบหรอ
ฟ้าโทรศัพท์ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตกลงไปในชักโครก
ที่ยังไม่ได้กด
ครูฟ้าก็จะเอามือ
เบอร์ของครูฟ้าแต่นะคะเราก็หยิบขึ้นมาหรอ
ใช่ 4 คู่หญิง
โทรศัพท์มันเลอะแล้วนะ
และแต่ก็ต้องหยิบครูหญิงก็ได้ยังไง
โทรศัพท์ของเราแล้วไฟฟ้าเนี่ยอ่ะเดี๋ยว
พี่ต้องรอกลับไปก่อนนะครับก็จบไปนักเรียน
กูฟ้าเนี่ยโทรศัพตกลงไปแล้วใช่ไหมมันก็
เลอะแล้วกูฝ่าก็หยิบขึ้นมาซึ่งลบก่อนนะ
ครับมีเห็นเองก็ไม่ค่อยโอเคนะคะ
[เพลง]
ฟ้าหยิบขึ้นมา
แล้วทำอะไรต่อฟ้าทำยังไงอ่ะไม่รู้มาตอบ
เลยภูฟ้าจะทำยังไงโทรศัพท์กูฟ้าตกลงไปใน
สักโครงที่แบบยังไม่ได้กดอ่ะเออกูฟ้าทำ
ยังไงอุบัติจะมีถุงพลาสติกค่ะนักเรียน
ทำอะไรเอาถุงพลาสติกหยิบไงโอ๋ใส่
ผู้หญิงเอาแล้วก็เอามือเนี่ยหยิบโทรศัพท์
ขึ้นมา
เบอร์
โทรศัพท์ขึ้นมา
เตอร์เนี่ยค่ะใช้ถุงพลาสติกกับผู้หญิง
แล้วทำอะไรต่อครูฟ้า
เสร็จแล้วกุมภาก็เอาโทรศัพท์เนี่ยอีกลบ
ให้ไม่ต้องล็อคก็ได้ทำมีที่อยู่อยู่ที่
หรอไปที่อยู่หรอนี่อยู่อ่ะต้องให้บอกไหม
ว่าที่ไหน
อะไรคะเนี่ยครูฟ้ากำลังว่าอะไรคะ
แล้วอย่าคิดว่าอะไรไม่บอกไม่รู้
เพราะว่าตรงนี้มันจะเป็นโซนในห้องน้ำใช่
มั้ยห้องน้ำ
อาร์โอฟาก็เอามาที่ซิงค์หรือว่าอาลายมือ
ใช้ค่ะเอาเออหยิบอ่างล้างมือ
มีเลยใช่ไหม
โทรศัพท์อ่ะคะแล้วก็
ไม่กูหญิงยังไงก็ต้องล้างอ่ะก็จะเอา
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยแล้วก็เปิดน้ำใช่ไหมเปิดน้ำ
กูก็จะล้างล้างล้างโทรศัพท์
เปิดไม่เป็นไรค่ะตอนนี้เราต้องใส่แม้ใช้
วินก็ไม่ได้เกรียนอะไร
กู
ไปต้องมีแชมพูหรือว่าสบู่ด้วยนะตัวนี้หนู
แต่ว่าที่อ่างล้างมือในห้องน้ำเนี่ยเขาจะ
มีสบู่ใช่ไหมสบู่ให้เราเนี่ยล้างมือ
r&i เนี่ยสบู่ก็จะกด
มันก็ล้างโทรศัพท์นะคะ
ล้าง
แล้วเอาไปเคลม ka
lon กี่ครั้งโรบาร์ก็น่าจะล้างประมาณ
4 ครั้งละกันมีสบู่แล้วก็ล้างครั้งที่คะ
แล้วก็ล้างครั้งที่ 2 แล้วก็ล้างครั้งที่
3 แล้วก็ล้างฟังที่ 4 ชายหาล้างล้างล้าง
ล้างสีครั้งถ้าไม่เหม็นใช่ไหมนมแล้วไม่
เหม็นก็โอเค
ลงเอาเป็นผู้หญิงเราไม่ต้องไม่ใช่ผู้หญิง
มีเคสจนปุ๋ยปุ๋ยอย่างเงี้ยผู้หญิงทิ้ง
เค้กนะคะเคสเน็ตทิ้งแน่นอนค่ะพี่คงต้อง
หนึ่งนับก่อนผู้หญิงจะล้างด้วยผู้หญิงก็
หยิบเหมือนกันแหละกูฟ้า
อะไรครับผู้หญิงมาผู้หญิงเราเป็นผู้หญิง
น้ำยังไงผู้หญิงก็คงหยิบเหมือนกันนะคะว่า
เมื่อคือโทรศัพท์ของเราเนาะเออมันมีรูป
ถ่ายเซ็กซี่ของเราอยู่ด้วย
อิอิเอ้าแต่ว่าผู้หญิงจะบอกปูปลาว่าที่
ผู้หญิงพูดก็คือผู้หญิงคงต้องถอดใช่ไหม
แกะเคสเนี่ยเบอร์โทรศัพท์หน่อยนะคะพี่
เค้าต้องถอดเคสโทรศัพท์ทิ้งก่อนก็คือเคส
เนี่ย Case ข้างนอกเนี่ยเคสชนิดแพงมากเลย
นะคะเสียดาย Case จังไม่ได้ทำอย่างก็ต้อง
ทิ้งอ่ะใช่ทิ้ง Case ก่อน
เห็นไหมแล้วผู้หญิงทำยังไงผู้หญิงก็ตอน
แรกผู้หญิงไม่รู้นะว่าจะทำยังไงแต่พอเห็น
ครูฟ้าก็คงล้างเหมือนกันแล้วค่ะใครจะถือ
โทรศัพท์เหม็นเหม็นๆที่ท่านรองน้ำผู้
หญิง
เรียนกินข้าวไม่อร่อยใช่ไหมก็คือเราก็
ต้องล้างนั่นแหละเพราะว่า
iPhone โดนน้ำโอเคนะหรอก็ iPhone โอเค
ใช่ไหมกับการโดนน้ำเพราะว่ามันก็คงโอเค
อ่ะหรือไม่เพราะอ่ะทีก็
เพราะว่านาน้ำที่อยู่ในซักโครกไหนในห้อง
น้ำมันมีนิดหน่อยเองเนาะมันแบบก็ตกลงไป
แต่มันไม่ได้โดนน้ำแบบเยอะๆหัวใจบัวฟ้า
พูดถูก
มันก็ยังโอเคแล้วโทรศัพท์ก็โอเคใช่ไหม
แล้วผู้ฟ้าโทรฮัลโหล
จะมีกลิ่นอะไรผู้หญิงเราต้องล้างเยอะๆนะ
คะแล้วต้องล้างล้างหลังศาลร้านก่อนค่ะฉีด
สเปรย์ alcohol ด้วยล้างเสร็จแล้วอ่ะเอ้า
เราก็เอา Apple  Apple  Store เอ้าก็หู
ฟ้าเนี่ยมีหลานสบู่ใช่ไหมสบู่เนี่ยมันก็
ฆ่าแบคทีเรียได้ไวรัสได้แต่ว่ายังไม่สบาย
ใจเวลาที่เราคุยโทรศัพท์เราต้องเอา
โทรศัพท์มาใกล้ๆหน้าไงเราก็จะ
โทรศัพท์ที่เคยตกน้ำเราก็เลยคิดสเปรย์
แอลกอฮอล์ฉีดฉีดฉีดอาจจะสบายใจมากกว่าไง
ดีเอาไปเคลมเนาะเปลี่ยน
หรอกูฟ้า
ทำโทรศัพท์ตกลงไปในชักโครกแล้วเอาไป
เปลี่ยนได้หรอเราบอกเขาเขาโอเคหรอเราก็
ไม่ต้องบอกเขาแต่เราฟิล์มเรียน
จะได้ว่ะมันต้องเพิ่มมันต้องบวกเงินนะคะ
ต้องบวกบวกเงินนั่นแหละ
ตอกอาจจะบวกเงินนิดหน่อยเพราะคิดว่ากูฟ้า
ในจะเปลี่ยนโทรศัพท์
แน่นอน
ทรายหะแต่ว่าก่อนที่ค่าโทรศัพท์ตกลงไปใน
ชักโครกแล้วใช่ไหมโทรศัพท์อันนี้แล้วก็ตก
ลงไปในสักครู่กแล้วอย่างแรกเลยที่ครูหญิง
ทำเนี่ยไม่ใช่หยิบขึ้นมานะฮะฟ้า
แล้วผู้หญิงจะทำอะไรให้โกรธแล้ว
ไม่มีอย่าลืม
ไม่ร้องไห้ทำไมคะ
กุ้งฟ้าหาโทรศัพท์ของเราแล้วนะมันตกลงไป
เนี่ยอย่างแรกที่ผู้หญิงคิดก็คือผู้หญิง
ต้องเปลี่ยนโทรศัพท์ใหม่แน่ๆเลย
แล้วเรื่องที่ดูว่าผู้หญิงเข้าห้องน้ำอ่ะ
ใช่ไหมผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเข้าห้องน้ำเนี่ย
เพราะว่าชีสไม่โอเคนะคะมันน่าจะเป็นน้ำ
จะเป็นดาวอ่ะ
ช่วย
วิ่งคิดเดิมนั้นอ่ะตลอดเลยเวลาเข้าห้อง
น้ำเนี่ยผู้หญิงจะระวังมากๆไม่ให้
โทรศัพท์เนี่ยหล่นลงไปใน
หล่นลงไปในซักโครกถึงแม้ว่าเราจะไม่ได้
ปวดท้องจะแค่ไปเข้าธรรมดาวีก็ไม่โอเคนะคะ
ใช่นั้นแล้วไม่ดีแล้วได้เรียน
รู้ครับผู้หญิงจะถามนักเรียน
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะนักเรียนคิดว่านักเรียน
เนี่ยถ้าทำโทรศัพท์ตกชักโครกนักเรียนจะทำ
ยังไง
นักเรียนเจอครูดิฐไหมหรือว่านักเรียนจะกด
ให้มันลงไปเลยปิดรวยไหมคะ
นักเรียนรวยไงนักเรียนก็เลยบอกว่าต้องคิด
ดีเก็บหรือว่ากดให้มันลงไปนะหรือว่านัก
เรียนทำยังไงก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะทำ
เปล่าไหมล้างหรือยังไงเนาะไม่รู้นะคะแต่
ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะเดี๋ยวเราสอง
คนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้า
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ